at this point it isn't clear that
anything would actually shock us about
the Trump riots but we have now learned
something that is sort of shocking about
the attempt to steal the election from
Joe Biden by Donald Trump
there was a PowerPoint
they put it in writing this was
happening at the highest levels of the
Trump Administration the plan was
extensive the plan was specific and
detailed and they actually implemented
certain elements of the plan of course
not succeeding and actually stealing the
election if it weren't totally
predictable it would be surprising but
it does come as a shock in terms of the
attack on Democracy that this
represented and four years ago we
certainly would not have imagined that
they would go this far we knew there was
a memo from a lawyer outlining
mechanisms that could be attempted to
try to steal the election from Joe Biden
but this became a PowerPoint
presentation with suggestions such as
declare a state of emergency
put in place a different slate of
electors and all of this is relevant
because for so long they denied the
rumors that they were thinking of
declaring a state of emergency that it
was ever a discussion so what this all
is about is a PowerPoint presentation
obtained by the house committee
investigating the Trump riots the
PowerPoint is called election fraud
foreign interference and options for
January 6th and these are options for
trying to prevent Joe Biden
from being certified as the winner which
of course he was the PowerPoint was
turned over to the investigative
committee by former Trump Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows it is real and it is
spectacular here are some slides from it
and of course all the rumors were true
they denied it all the things we
believed they were planning they were
indeed planning first slide called
options for January 6th lists VP Pence
seats Republican electors over the
objections of Dems in states where fraud
occurred
we knew they were planning this just
Mike Pence says because there is fraud
in Arizona
instead of seeding the Democratic
electors we have an alternate slate of
Republican electors insane insane second
option VP Pence rejects electors from
states where fraud occurred causing the
election to be decided by the remaining
electoral vote so the idea there is if
you just take off the table some of the
electors instead of needing 270 now
maybe you only need 230 or 210 or
whatever the idea is you take enough
States off the table that Trump's actual
electors that he did win are more than
50 that was the second option third
option VP Pence delays decision to allow
for vetting and accounting of legal
paper ballots the idea being well they
would say a ton of these are not legal
and throw them out that was a slide for
the coup
like a book report but for a coup
another slide called recommendations
actually says on it declare a National
Security emergency
claim foreign interference and control
of voting systems remember they denied
denied denied that there was even a
vulnerability to foreign actors back in
2016. now all of a sudden they want to
use it was let's use it ourselves to
steal the election and then third
recommendation declare electronic voting
in all states invalid they denied they
were thinking about this stuff and it is
on the PowerPoint
um in another slide called summary of
domestic voter fraud they list all of
the things that they eventually did Trot
out now this stuff they tried okay
double voters people voted twice dead
voters that one we spent a lot of time
debunking non-citizen voters they can't
even register to vote fake ballots like
just a ballot you make at home I guess
they list eight states they are exactly
the states that they talked about
Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Minnesota Georgia Nevada
Arizona New Mexico
they did all of it this was the game
plan they tried it fortunately they
didn't get away with it now they didn't
ultimately try declaring the National
Security emergency or maybe Trump did
and someone stopped him when we don't
know yet
we just have to wait so there's a few
takeaways here
confirmed for the tenth time they were
lying all along about what they were
planning what they were thinking of what
they would be willing to do it was lie
after lie after lie confirmation not
surprising second we were right about
this being very serious and probably
something they're going to try again now
we all had a good old time laughing at
the wacky stuff right Rudy giuliani's
face melting the hair dye Sydney Powell
visibly perplexed by her own arguments
you know oh okay I get it Trump the big
baby still won't admit he lost all of it
but this is not a game and when I said
last week in my commentary based on a
article that we talked about
um the next coup is already being
planned the first attempt was practice
for the next one this is very serious
this is not the last we've heard from
this idea now third and last
when does the Department of Justice get
involved Merrick Garland has been very
hesitant I can understand the reasons
why he might feel that it would not
maybe be good to get involved in this
but how does the doj justify not getting
involved when every single fact is so
utterly insane and dangerous that's the
question that remains and we can't put
our guard down even for a second
if you're having trouble thinking of
what to give someone as a holiday gift
check out our sponsor Shaker and Spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
delivering the ingredients and recipes
for craft cocktails right to your door
they send you everything you need to
make the cocktails except for the
alcohol you provide that it comes with a
really nice recipe card easy to follow
my most recent Shaker and Spoon cocktail
creation was called The Capri Crush it's
a Campari and gin drink with spiced
Orange grapefruit cordial and dash fire
orange bitters delicious my turned out
great I know nothing about mixing drinks
neither do most of my friends but with
my shaker and Spoon cocktails I ended up
looking like I knew something about it
which is good it's very good for my cred
you don't have to go to a crowded bar to
enjoy an excellent cocktail shaker and
Spoon lets you do it all at home great
for date nights makes a perfect gift and
you'll get twenty dollars off when you
use the promo code Pacman at checkout go
to shakerandspoon.com Pacman and the
link is down below